running backs make it off the board in
the second half of round one the first
one to go the steelers
almost 50 years after drafting franco
harris 13th overall they take najee
harris from alabama at 24. chris i was
told earlier this week that if xavien
collins was gone and he was and audrey
harris was going to be a pick for the
steelers what no one was told was that
with the next election the jaguars would
go travis atn the clemson running back
an immediate reunion with trevor
lawrence his college quarterback they
are dabo swinney or urban meyer i was
stunned by that one well it makes sense
though as far as the way both teams want
to play football and yeah you were all
over it i mean you you uh the zavin
collins to the cardinals like you called
that too like look at you john johnny
prediction
and that's the thing there's a
difference between a mock draft and yeah
for information i know guard is reliable
right but i've regarded it as reliable
that the cardinals are going to take
xavier collins if jaylen waddle patrick
certain and jc horn were gone and that
happened and that the steelers were
going to take
najee harris if dave and collins right
on and that happened those were two
things that i was certain about going
into the end of the night and got lucky
for it well i mean it just tells us the
direction of the steelers right they're
gonna get try to get back to what we've
been talking about you know ground and
pound play defense let big ben hit some
one-on-one shots outside and dodgy
harris it's not like gonna be 60 and 70
yard runs but he's unreal at catching
the ball out of the field and it's going
to be a ton of a lot of great five and
10 yard runs that's what you're gonna
get for naji harris you know so that
that's cool and i think it does fit with
the way they want to play atn to clemson
that's the one i really i mean that
comes into seems like clemson to
jacksonville i mean that does excite me
you know it really does first off that's
they're gonna play the urban meyer
college spread offense and atn is yeah
he can run between the tacos but he's an
awesome open field player running routes
out of the backfield but just giving him
space and his ability to make people
miss or run for 60 70 yard touchdowns he
has it all i mean for me he was the best
running back in the draft i like the
pick for jacksonville i didn't think
they'd go in the first round but but
good for them but when you got james
robinson a year after they showed you
don't need to use
any pick on a running back that's what
stunned me you got james robinson why
are you going to burn a first round pick
one of your jayla and ramsay selections
on a running back and as you said you
mentioned clemson i think they could
just peel off the jaguar profile and put
the paw print well on there i think the
hoof i think
the paul though i mean the
joke i think they're telling you though
like i know i got it from goodfellas i
got you the paw the hoof i got it i'm
there it didn't go over me um but i i
think they're telling you they think atn
is special i mean atn the guy that you
know i i saw louis riddick last night on
espn that's the guy i said during my
podcast a few weeks ago and he did
running backs he is very alvin kamara
ish and i like james robinson but he's
not alvin kamara ish you know so i do
think you have a chance to get a really
really special runner here with atn and
i think you know with urban meyer high
pace shotgun offense he wants two good
running backs you know it could be hey
slants you know slant route by you know
uh trevor lawrence you know inside zone
read play atn oh now now lawrence keeps
the ball off the edge atn screen oh
you're tired here comes james robinson
no huddle we're still going oh we faked
it to james robinson now he's throwing a
deep go route to dj shark that's the
kind of offense they're gonna run so i
think that's probably why why you know
at ohio state in florida he had platoons
of running backs and i think that's
probably part of the you know thought
process uh from the outside looking in
here
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports